Thank you Andrea and I arena for joining us here today.
Uh,
at Google we talk a lot about the user.
yeah,
I spent two and a half years in mountain view as a pm on a couple of different
products.
And whenever I talked about the user,
I would look at a dashboard and that dashboard would have various numbers and
graphs of the number of users in different countries,
the level of engagement that they had on a day to day or week to week basis.
And that was my touchpoint.
Um,
but I think why I'm so grateful that you're joining us here today is that you
represent the user and it's so much more tangible sense.
You are journalists on the front lines of it's super important issue for Google.
You know,
our mission is to organize the world's information,
make it accessible and useful,
and that is what you do everyday.
You organize information and very sensitive,
very challenging topics and you make it accessible and useful to the world.
Um,
and so my hope today is that we can get into what that process looks like,
how technology has helped and hindered.
Um,
and what the folks in this room who cared about these issues can do to
contribute going forward.
Um,
to begin with,
maybe if you're comfortable just sharing a little bit about your backgrounds,
um,
the work you do and the places that you do it in.
Well,
thank you Justin.
Thank you everybody for coming off for having us.
Uh,
US has sat and Justin said,
ah,
we are,
as the Russian investigative journalist,
and we've been doing this for almost 17 years.
Uh,
VFR focus on the Russian secret services,
uh,
Enza led the fall zones.
Uh,
we,
uh,
start off investigations,
a change and digital landscape and as a country,
and uh,
in 2012,
it became quite apparent that,
uh,
is a Kremlin,
God scaring all over the Internet and the most layer,
uh,
because of the Arab spring and the Moscow protests in 2011,
2012.
So it was a criminal and Stata,
they're massive,
uh,
offensive on internet freedoms in our country.
Uh,
first name was Sanka food might enlighten me here.
And as Andrea mentioned,
as this time,
uh,
about,
Internet censorship wasn't I in Russia became a s thought four item,
our new book,
uh,
Zara and web as a criminal swore on the Internet,
which was published in [inaudible] in 2015 here in the United States.
Uh,
but,
um,
since 2015,
uh,
have been,
Manny developments in,
uh,
Russia and u s relationship and notably during the US election and we filed,
is that,
uh,
is that it was very important to write about this and to share what we found of
is,
uh,
by edit by Ed and a new chop,
the,
uh,
to choose a book and the Cold Age Zero Red Web comes to the United States and it
was published or this,
this all goes.
So let's talk about how censorship works in Russia.
Can you give me a little bit of a sense of on a day to day basis what the
experience of someone in Russia is like as relates to censorship
while onto the sofas?
It looks like we have old elements,
uh,
technological elements of,
off censorship.
We have,
uh,
Internet filtering system.
We have lots of black lists,
not one of bonnet websites.
And we have a,
an extensive system of a online.
So,
and it's extremes intrusive,
uh,
extremely excellent.
It's a system of back doors to all services,
uh,
in our country for provided for the Russian secret services.
And we also have,
unfortunately,
they have people sent to jail for posting something,
a sensitive or critical of the Kremlin.
But at the same time,
it's quite clear that this system technological is not very,
I would say effective,
uh,
internet filter in this porous.
Uh,
for example,
if you want to,
if you believe that you need to access a blocked website,
you can use very simple methods,
a simple tools.
You don't need even to use VPN.
You can use Google.
Translate is also hubs.
Anyone from Google translate here today,
I'll say hello.
And,
um,
if you want to communicate securely,
you still have fears,
a Biz ops and you can use a messenger's.
A lots of them are extremely popular in Russia and they that aren't in a sort of
a new media.
Uh,
so,
but still,
uh,
the system,
is quite effective in a salad,
a silencing people who want to talk about,
uh,
things online,
open there.
And,
um,
I think the idea of the criminal approach is,
uh,
to be based more on intimidation then technology.
And actually it's a very Soviet approach.
Uh,
when we do social for our book,
we checked how things were organized,
beckons the Soviet times.
And one of the most astonishing thing,
uh,
we found out is that the KGB is a powerful security to service.
Uh,
was technically,
it was not very advanced.
Uh,
it's a hate of powers of the KGB.
it was capable of eavesdropping on,
on,
uh,
300 phone calls simultaneously
in read 100 phone calls at the same time.
That was,
that was the cap.
Yeah,
that was nice and nice and wide.
It was frightened by as a kid to be in the side of things.
So absolutely.
They know how,
how to send a message,
but everybody should be very,
very cautious and it looks like they use the same approach today is send a
message.
They can pick up some people,
send them to jail and that would,
and does that work when they send folks to jail,
you know,
whether it's an activist,
a journalist,
someone else.
Um,
how,
what happens,
well happens blogger as that's not about journalists.
Journalists haven't been Santam's Ireland,
Russia,
um,
that people found at Zion Jael.
Uh,
was that,
uh,
some,
some kind of protest in the cities for Muslim Moscow and that's all or those
protests effective no Sunday at one time.
So it was a fact of plan a blogger,
a blogger who went to the church and play and play it,
uh,
Pokemon goal and then posted a video on youtube,
was sent to jail for it pauses for postings as leader because it is where it is
very fancy for the Orthodox church in Russia.
And there are the special,
a special,
a special article lodge as a criminal court.
He was done two child,
uh,
at,
incited a lot of protests are on the Internet,
on Youtube,
everywhere and even on the street.
And,
uh,
after this protest,
he was,
uh,
release the US wailed and he wasn't relieved,
but he's under,
under,
under her,
under house arrest.
And that's,
that's okay.
So what are,
what are people's views on censorship in Russia?
Do people generally think that this is a good system or do you think it's a bad
system?
Are they just indifferent?
They accepted as a way of life.
I just beginning in the thousand and 12,
[inaudible] introduces a Internet filtering system and the contract general
public was not very interested in this.
And I,
if you didn't notice any attention to this issue.
So we try to,
to attract a lot of attentions but will fail.
But after then,
I,
a few years ago was a Kremlin made two big mistakes,
uh,
as a Caribbean blocked,
the,
as the most popular torrent websites in the country.
And then they tried to block porn hub after that.
Even people,
even people who have never been interested in Russian politics are in politics
at all.
Uh,
started learning how to use circumvention tools.
So the Russia in a week after his biggest passion to run the website was
blocked.
The trait,
you mean Vittoria the illegal file sharing service.
Yeah.
So almost immediately in a big rush has skyrocketed to the second position and
the number of total users.
Now we are second on that is in other states
toward the,
the anonymous routing service.
Yes.
These famous VPN,
which is provided for free.
Got It.
So as long as they don't go after your illegal file sharing or your pornography,
it's all good.
But once they cross those lines,
people got agitated,
upset the thing.
Has there been any on the political side,
any mobilization or any cases where anyone has engaged in the same way?
Yeah,
I think so because,
uh,
in use is idea of internet filter and it was sold to the public on the pretext
of protecting children against pedophiles and against people who spreads and
suicidal notes.
Something really strange.
But people accepted this because it's all about children.
Uh,
but five years passed and now everybody understood it's not about wow children.
That's about politics and the vizio.
We got a street protest actually in Moscow.
We got Marsha's,
we got,
uh,
we got big events and uh,
as a Russian pilot parts here organize some of his events.
And if you get,
if you've got falling off people protesting in the Russian pirate party.
Yes.
It's a very popular thing and come so far.
But actually they monitor a lot of things about Internet censorship and also
we're trying to organize some things offline and there's,
the latest a protest was really huge.
It was about thousands of people.
That's very cool.
Um,
isn't the pirate party running Iceland incidentally?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's a big inspiration for all branches of the pirate parts everywhere.
Huh.
Very cool.
So turning to technology a little bit,
um,
is there anything
you can share,
you mentioned earlier that,
you know,
there's this technological censorship regime in Russia,
but it sounds like it's only effective to a point.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Well,
I think that's a problem is that when you have,
is the Internet in Account Chair built for almost 20 years,
uh,
it does about any kind of,
intrusion from the government.
And that was the case for Russia for,
yeah,
for almost 20 years.
From 1991 to 2011.
Um,
it's actually,
it's extremely difficult technological it to add this element of censorship and
filtering,
you need to breads a redesign already fine.
The entire infrastructure of the Internet.
It's,
um,
it's extremely difficult as a rationale for just found out last year they even
tried to enlist some support from Chinese as a Chinese.
Uh,
went to Moscow said like,
we are happy to,
how bad do you need to get rid of all American equipment?
It's a problem is about that.
It's a,
it's really difficult to counter to place say in one day old Cisco and such a
big country,
we have something produced in China.
Uh,
so that's why I know about trying to find the way hard to remodel the critical
infrastructure of the Internet in Russia.
But it's,
um,
it's a very tricky and I don't see any mal successes so far.
Uh,
initially,
uh,
I,
in fact ours was the rational story.
This was frightened at to replace as an American to equipment buys a Chinese
equipment,
Chinese offer it to,
to put into the system who I always equate highway equipment.
And so that's what frightened for the Russian security services because cause I
am very suspicious to Chinese,
Chinese.
Yeah.
Solid also invented the US.
Well I don't think you need to convince that room of Google or is that doing a
whole scale infrastructure,
a swap out is going to be technologically hard.
Um,
how about on the sort of consumer side?
Do you know you guys are,
are,
you know,
individual actors,
um,
you know,
you don't have the resources of a large player.
How do you use technology in your work?
Is it a force for good?
Is it a hindrance?
What are your thoughts on that?
Is all technology wouldn't be who they are because we set up our website
[inaudible] dot [inaudible] back into south by commercial Salzman and a very
young journalists.
We didn't have any,
uh,
any money to pay for peninsula calls for paper.
Uh,
and about Avaya,
spend a little money for months,
uh,
maintaining our websites and the cost us a very cheap we can do,
we can continue doing our work.
And also it's a,
it's actually,
it's extremely important for us because,
um,
for many reasons it's a,
now it's became really difficult to find a place for publishing your stories in
the country.
Uh,
it's not a coincidence what we have,
uh,
both of our books signs it first was published in the thousand and 10.
It's was all about the Russian secret services as the second one read web and
the both of them that publish it first in the United States.
Uh,
but to communicate before publisher,
of course you need technology.
Uh,
and,
uh,
thanks to Skype and Google hangout a while you,
you,
you can do my be in Moscow still communication,
uh,
with,
if your editors and publishers,
which is a great thing.
And also of course,
it's helps us to gather intelligence,
information and intelligence and uh,
in a way,
because you kind of use all kinds of,
uh,
things like net,
they're mining and now it's extremely important.
Uh,
in Russia you can use all these databases and you can find some really exposing
stuff.
Uh,
like some years ago,
thanks to one database we found out that,
uh,
now we have in Russia,
not one system of online surveillance mansard by one security service,
but eight of them honey.
He different systems online surveillance.
Yes.
I build sa about superintendents led by eight agencies.
Uh,
and uh,
we just found out that thanks to data mining because officially you cannot get
any,
uh,
any Coleman's from various agencies because it's considered to be state
cigarette and sometimes technology switch,
uh,
not meant to be used by journalists.
Uh,
bow proved to be extremely helpful.
For example,
drones and a while,
some years ago,
I think he's about seven years ago,
80,
and that had a very big investigation about the luxury villas.
They should be given for free to the FSB Russian security services generals.
And I think that time you never fought what you can actually approach it.
It was impossible to pro.
I got information,
I checked all documents.
Uh,
it was clear as large as his generals,
uh,
just grabbed a state,
a state real estate for free.
And my day I had no chance to abroad does Israel state and,
and take a picture because it was very well guarded by the security to Samosas
and uh,
it was hidden arms are huge fans and that challenge sales.
But now I could,
I can do this easily to wants a drone.
Actually we got,
uh,
yeah,
some,
some interesting things.
So on,
uh,
available on a [inaudible],
it's mostly done by,
uh,
Russian opposition leader in the wireless team.
And they got this team of,
and they can actually be a launch,
a drone souls the time.
And the most recent example,
they just,
I think it was three weeks ago,
we exposed and use secret,
a luxury villa renovated specifically for a Putin's personal use.
And it's a,
it's,
it's crazy for this.
You can see everything and uh,
pallets.
It's amazing.
And it's on Youtube.
You say exactly.
That's how they get to,
you mentioned that there are eight different agencies.
Can you give a little bit more color on that?
The kind of things that they're looking at?
I mean,
you,
you said earlier that they're filtering,
you know,
Internet stuff,
but with eight different agencies,
is that all they're doing or are there other activities?
No,
of course be they have other activities to do,
but we have the right to conduct these kinds of situations.
So because now we had this climate,
uh,
in Russia by attacks,
actually,
if you ask for some funds for the secret services all,
it's fine.
We're going to put you in this very hybrid to provide those funds.
So is the agencies just use this opportunity to build their own systems of a
online store balance?
The tricky thing about this surveillance,
which is it's not like muscle balance,
uh,
because there are still some technical problems,
for the Russian secret services are,
especially for example,
they do not know how to build huge databases.
They still rely on American technologists like Oracle Ivans.
Uh,
to be honest,
even the internal database of,
as the FSB is built on Oracle.
Wow.
Uh,
so they,
they do not know how to do those things.
So instead of mass surveillance where do targeted surveillance,
which means that we need first to know who should be spied on and when they
started the thing.
But in a way it's extremely effective in making,
uh,
the IT industry in the Russia complicit in these activities because what
actually it means admins.
But if you are small or big Internet service provider in Moscow or in any town,
you need to get a license in one of the finger in his license is a,
you are required to install I special equipment,
so called black box,
uh,
of uh,
which actually a backdoor for that you need to get,
um,
a plan of implementation from the local branch of safe is B.
And actually it means that you need to get along with his guys and you're
provided a contact number.
Uh,
so a guy from the local branch cause all of us,
uh,
about coal year and ask for some favors.
And also you have physical,
a cable which connects your servers with the local branch of safe is B.
And you know nothing about what actually is intercepted on your services because
it's all state secret and you have no security clearance as ISP.
You have no access sometimes even to the room where you have this black box.
So it's actually,
it's a back door,
but also it's a phone number.
So you might be one day asked for to set down some website or my bid to look
into some someone's,
um,
Mao emails accounts and to provide it to,
to the FSB as a favor.
How do decide who to target?
So that's complicated.
Uh,
um,
in fact,
uh,
they have to combat crimes but aside crimes,
nausea,
uh,
one of the environment in,
in,
in particular region or in most say and die and adjust the patrols,
uh,
was a victim.
Uh,
usually,
mostly this is a person who was known for,
for his or political activity or some oppositional activity or publishing,
Samsung,
critical of the Kremlin.
And one's a,
one's a designated this as a standard.
As I started to monitor all his activity on the Internet.
And,
uh,
this is enough for our,
sometimes it's enough for sending hemophilia to prison for,
oh,
let me give one example.
One guy was sent to prison for two years on the foot Boston on his,
uh,
on his page or on a social network [inaudible] which was modeled after Facebook,
somewhat popular in Russia.
Uh,
a big draws off of,
uh,
of,
of two spaced,
um,
of a tube of toothpaste and southern clause was alike or legs squeeze Russia out
of yourself.
I got two years.
Sorry.
I don't understand it.
Was it two faces has squeeze Russia out of your,
she'll spiced and squeeze Russia out of yourself.
That's Rosa phobic.
W what does it even saying though?
Does it,
what does that mean?
Nobody actually to understand is there was an allusion is that,
is that as an allusion to,
to,
to uh,
to Samsung cough,
rash and right.
The chair off are,
that means you need to,
um,
Korea is a slave.
A slave when it from yourself.
Okay.
But at the same time,
it's all really stupid.
That's doesn't mean it named got him two years in prison.
Yes.
Wow.
Have you had near brushes with,
with those kinds of experiences?
Well,
we,
as I said,
we started many years ago.
I think it was two falls in 1999 to four hours.
And then of course,
uh,
back then actually it started very older for us older than the falls.
And then Toby got very felt criminal investigation against us.
Uh,
and sometimes it's really,
um,
I would say,
well do you feel really nervous because we isn't corrugation cyber I conducted
in a prison actually,
and just by chance,
so you would never know,
ah,
what might happen to you next.
Uh,
and uh,
maybe you would stay,
there might be not a,
it's a,
it's a big question,
but I would say that we've full,
well if you tried to and lot to understand how things changed,
I would say that today is,
the tactics became much more supple.
So back then it was mostly about targeting individual journalists.
Uh,
and now it's about how to deal with editors and owners of the media and which
results in the situation when you cannot find a place to get your stuff.
And you cannot say that look,
um,
in a way it's,
it's worse because when you have a,
someone a is targeted by buys a Kremlin,
it means what it at least with journalists could,
uh,
could apply to public.
He might make his case public and say,
look,
I'm a victim of,
uh,
this kind of pressure,
but now solid kind of management problem.
It's between you and you editor,
right?
It's the same philosophy where there is the cable,
but there's also the phone number.
Right?
And it's all kind of done manual through d.
Yeah,
very manual.
That's a good way to think about it.
Um,
and you mentioned earlier that your book was published in the US was,
it was published here before Russia,
is that correct?
Why is that?
Uh,
because,
uh,
Russian publishers today then not very well understood the risks and,
um,
because it's a long story for us.
So we started publishing this stuff in,
uh,
in,
in the west,
maybe in 2010,
2009.
So we had kind of experience,
and it's really interesting that Russell Publications,
they sometimes they pick up your stories,
but only after they,
uh,
they,
they published it,
buys a Western publications and they always ask to,
to maintain these byline.
But first time this was published in English and say it's the Gotcha.
Okay.
So,
so it's helps them to shift responsibility and to sell.
It was already published somewhere.
And the same goes with the books,
a survey,
say a bowel,
the maybe one day we are hyper to publish your book,
but first get one published in the West and actually buy those happen.
We,
we got our book finally published in Russia,
but only after it was published in,
uh,
in the United States.
So sort of a boomerang outside and strategist.
And I'm actually surprised to hear that you were able to publish your book in
Russia at all.
Well,
why is that?
Maybe because of Phil's book was,
uh,
became Apicella.
[inaudible] actually had met a lot of money for the publisher in regulations and
uh,
not for us.
Dolan says Basa at the was a really strange moment in Russian history because it
was,
uh,
September of 2011.
And uh,
the book was just published and the FSB was not very hyper surveys send some
letters.
Actually we sent some people to for some strange reasons why decided to these
the present house.
Why?
Yeah,
I don't,
I still don't know.
So security services showed up at the printing house.
Yes.
Nothing's officers of the publisher buttons,
a printing house and asking crazy questions like who paid for the preaching of
the book and everybody's okay pop a publisher.
But uh,
and we were really nervous bots.
Then we got these Moscow protests.
So the FSB,
uh,
very soon they had some other things to do,
we needed to deal with or face political crisis.
And did they ever come back to the printing house?
No,
they forgot about it completely.
And whatever works,
I guess it's all people.
And that's one of the themes that I think if the points you've been making that
there is a technology,
but it really is as much manual is it is automatic.
Yeah.
So looking forward a little bit and we're going to pause in a few minutes.
So folks that have questions as we go,
just be jotting them down and then we'll open it up for any audience questions
momentarily.
But before we do that,
I just want to turn to the future a little bit.
Um,
where do you see things going?
Huh,
Huh?
Yeah.
You know about John Willis than we had to predict future and always failed.
But even even,
uh,
Watson cause absolutely predictable is that London we'll put in will be as any
new Russian president next year.
Yeah.
All right,
Bob.
Well,
I think that,
uh,
if you try to see is the whole thing,
maybe we still have some,
some sorts for hope because it looks like we have the Internet,
uh,
as a criminal on face as a formidable challenge because it's historically the
whole Russian history actually,
ah,
has been defined and by hierarchical order.
Uh,
we all this had someone on the voter top while Conan shots.
It was,
maybe it's a zoll maybe as an emperor or my visit leader of the Communist Party.
But right now,
uh,
we are Gielan VFS situation.
What we have is we have the network,
we have our,
which is by definition is a horizontal Keisha and it looks like the Kremlin has
some problems understanding the nature of the network.
Um,
just pretty big.
Three years ago we had an excellent example.
Uh,
there was a case against his guy,
the Waianae,
and he was about to be sent to jail and some,
some of his people,
I,
they wanted to mobilize people to protest.
So we'll launch the protest group on Facebook.
And this group was immediately a two down by taking down,
by,
by Facebook,
under request of the Russian government.
And immediately if got a lot of people are treasured Bobby's story,
launching their own pages,
uh,
asking people to God to get a to a particular place in Moscow.
And,
uh,
as a result,
we got tons of Falzone's people protesting on the Moscow streets.
10 thousands of people spontaneously,
but kind of stay just black lab.
So I think via Sphinx is still very difficult for the client to understand and
it gives us some hope.
Yeah.
But still believes is that the Internet is ruled by some guys who was a top and
his science.
This is a CA.
Yeah.
Actually that really,
yeah,
he actually has,
yeah.
Saturday as a CIA.
Internet was a creation.
Hmm.
And,
and in general,
how do they think about technology?
So that's one,
you know,
data point.
How do you think,
you know,
five years from now there'll be sort of conceptualizing the internet?
Well,
in our business and in before for the media to be all about social media and we
already have some interesting things,
but people tried to abandon the idea of domain names from a media.
Uh,
they actually been moved to social media.
So we have some recent project and [inaudible] project and which was launched
solely on social media.
They have a page on Facebook of page on contacted and something on medium.com.
That's all.
And it's not only because we believe in the idea of social media,
but also because it's more secure.
Once you have a website and domain name,
it might be blocked,
you might get some visitors and if you have everything based on social media,
but provides you with some opportunity and a simultaneously some people who
still believe in the idea of domain names that I think that now maybe it's time
to,
to move to Google because it's also big issue,
uh,
for safe as a contraceptive authoritarian regimes.
One thing is to blog a website of a particular media.
It's easier,
especially if it's a Russian registered registrator it's uh,
but if it's based on,
it's actually physically on Google,
it means if you want to block it,
you need to deal with the whole Google.
And it's such a sensitive thing for many that even in the countries so far,
Central Asia,
and they're usually,
they're not that subtle,
they're still hesitant and they do not know what to do with his new phenomenon
that many media might be physically based on Google services.
They just don't know how to deal with this program.
So maybe that provides us again,
some sense of,
uh,
some,
maybe some sorts of help.
Do you foresee any changes to the policies or the laws or the enforcements
around that?
While the problem is that we have this problem as idea of,
um,
uh,
of localization,
the idea that,
uh,
ahead with the stone,
but the Balkanization of the Internet,
unfortunately it's,
it's such a great idea for many,
especially in Russia and China will loves idea of a brand that,
a digital surveillance here and erase.
So veterans sovereignty,
sovereign digital sovereignty,
uh,
and it's basically,
it's about borders.
Like we have our territory and it's,
it's a,
it's a limited by borders.
We need to have exactly the same thing,
uh,
on the Internet.
And the idea is that if you have some service at might be Facebook,
Twitter,
any,
anything,
uh,
Google,
you need to,
uh,
have,
old servers.
They have the Russian,
uh,
with this particular country,
a citizen's data on this territory.
Just to be able to access it easily and to manipulate.
Maybe it is data and unfortunately it's a very appealing idea to many because
it's a,
it's something about patriotism.
Like,
yes,
we are.
For example,
we bought some meeting with the Russian officials and they,
they said very openly,
yes,
we are very grateful to as Americans we invented the whole thing.
But now it's time for us to control our space.
It's about our sense of,
uh,
of the national state.
Mm.
It was a great opportunity for security to sauces to get access to users.
Jose,
they're not able to,
uh,
to just buy owns on the site,
on the services are located abroad because it was,
I can't,
uh,
as I can find that direct access to.
So last question before return to the audience overall,
are you an optimist?
The pessimist?
Do you think that,
you know,
the Internet will be a force for good five,
10 years from now?
Or do you think,
you know,
we're sort of in this unique window in history that's going to close?
Well,
you know that Alan just started writing the whole book.
I will publish an American publisher said,
look,
you need to add something optimistic and sand of your book because otherwise why
to read it.
And
finally we thought,
wow,
might be better.
It's significant in the end VI's idea.
But seriously,
no,
the optimists,
they believe that we right now it's a,
we have these opportunities can uh,
we can publish those kinds of stories and it's old and thanks to technology and
it looks like for the Kremlin they might know some tricks.
Bots.
It's really difficult for them to catch up if US development of technologies.
And also the problem is,
which also gives me some hope,
uh,
just Vizhier [inaudible] you information security doctrine and it's essentially
a Soviet,
it's actually has one thing that before introducing some new technologies,
a telecommunication companies should thoughts,
consultants,
a secret services.
And we knew that that actually back in the Soviet times that destroyed the
telecommunication market and our country.
Because if you need to ask someone who is wise enough to think about security
while it just slow down everything and that gives some,
yeah,
that gives us hope.
How does it give you hope?
That seems like a,
well it's my,
no,
it's a,
it's a warning.
Tell him so bad that it would slow down z say internet business in our country.
But in terms of Phi given the cow,
uh,
I'll uh,
the forces of,
uh,
control some,
some new means.
I think now the VA,
they're all this.
Um,
uh,
I would say no for vitamins,
just difficult to catch up phase all of this a bit slow.
I see.
It's a,
it's evidence that the mindset has not been evolving.
Yup.
Got It.
When you've,
when you first,
then you need to choose what's the most important thing?
Cause it's the forefront of technologies of security and you always to security.
It means what?
You lose something very important that we live in a world when,
when development of technologies,
essential thing and if you all this trade it for security or for the ghost of
security,
you lose.
Got It ready.
You can't,
it's not going to be viable to keep up with the international technology scene
if that's the impression.
What do you think Eric?
Uh,
icings.
That crown is always losing to the technologies because it's crammed and doesn't
understand the nature of the Internet.
And that was,
that is very advantage as far as what if I go to the beacon mentors for us.
Well,
thank you so much for the work that you do for sharing it with us today and for
taking the time to answer these questions.
And I'll it over now,
but let's do
a round of applause.
Okay.
Hi,
I'm,
so speaking of a digital sovereignty,
what's,
what are your thoughts and what's the sentiment coming out of Russia around the,
the fake news phenomena that has essentially determine the elections of the u s
don't sense that a Russian Russians or Russian fake use determine that as a
result of the u s election.
We believe as that is that Trump was elected because of a central reason sa,
uh,
and the Americans wanted to believe him.
But of course,
uh,
does this machine that produce fake news trolls and so on are to some extent the
effective and a special ed and Tom Solve,
disrupt and discussion on the Internet and to dissemination of our senior
season.
Amanza Internet users.
What was the criminal,
what does a motorcycle,
Rhonda of the Cram,
and there's this Arrow's I'm honest,
I'm honest of trolls are spreading a negative information about Arizona,
about,
uh,
about Potter's,
about,
uh,
representatives of different groups of pop off population about political
leaders and post you,
it puts you in a very vulnerable position.
You can't,
uh,
you feel as though you can't believe anybody and so on.
So it doesn't matter who will be your new president or maybe it's the old two
old strong leader is better than any new leader.
That's what was that?
What was I doing?
What I see is that the kind of Poles,
I mean democracy,
Tanner Paul's does this sinks on developing a good,
uh,
good.
Our mass media,
good quality and the progressive mass media also does the way how it could be,
how we can combat the sink propaganda.
Maybe it's a fingers,
which we need to understand that this all started in our country.
And a first layer as a first target was the Russian political opposition and
independent journalism.
And unfortunately it was very successful in Russia,
mostly because we still are very confused society post Soviet Post authoritarian
society.
I'll be for lack of trust in anything,
especially in political institutions.
And that's who,
and it lets you,
when you think of it,
you,
it left you with the idea what you have the general public,
uh,
as a population and the leader and that's all,
nothing in between.
And that's,
that's what's used by buys a crime to the fool because of this case.
While you think,
well at least he's guy,
he's strong enough.
We know who he,
who he is and we do not know all of the guys.
So it's better to keep the fish guy and it looks like push and just tried to,
this idea of complete distrust in institutions.
Does the United States,
I do not believe that it was born.
It was invented by Putin here.
I mean you already had some basis for this kind of mistrust and and in,
in the establishment and the media.
So what they tried to do with trying to explore it with filling edits on fool
and unfortunately it was successful to some to some degree.
I,
I as a journalist,
I'm a bit skeptical whether it's completely changes the game and,
but of course we had a softball.
So if I'm hearing you right,
just to summarize,
it was as much about changing the level of overall trust in our society over a
long period of time as it wasn't about any particular election.
Yeah,
yeah.
I have a question kind of along the same lines.
So I was at the Oxford Internet institute back in 2010 kind of studying the
beginnings of computational propaganda.
And today I have friends who are journalists at NBC,
big news outlets who were being tasked with covering these types of things.
And I get questions from them like,
is this actually real?
And so considering that,
and this is their job.
And so considering that you've seen this in Russia many times in terms of like
disinformation campaigns,
are there any trends that you've seen evolve in Russia that you think could make
the leap to the u s
well,
to be honest,
it looks like the,
but it's thought that in the West and Venture 14 Moseley,
uh,
and uh,
because of the annexation of Crimea.
And firstly it was as if first tiger toss Ukraine and it was easier because we
share the same language,
the same pursuit.
It says the same,
a furious about how bar hold Wulfila buzzer worst and a and our history.
So you can play the same tricks for the Russian and for Ukrainians.
Then they tried something in a,
in eastern Europe,
uh,
to some extent it was really successful once again because lots of people on
this to Europe,
Phil a a bit,
I would say fooled by the West.
They have a promise at the Lord and it was never delivered.
And um,
find the limit.
Tried in engine United Kingdom.
I've tried to the garden and they immediately got spot.
So it was not a big success.
Um,
mostly for some language problems.
Uh,
and of course it was mostly because people who back then the harder to do this
kind of things.
Uh,
we were Russians based in the same pitcher of milk and some other places,
but unfortunately,
uh,
it's evolved with time and now,
it looks like they got some people based in these countries who are at his
bottle natives so they know how to speak a how to on Bryce,
the issues which are really important for this particular region of his
particular district.
And they use this kind of thing still.
I do not believe that it's that effective.
Uh,
but what makes ma'am,
but to curl there,
uh,
about crucial,
ends up Clemons propaganda Fang,
that we have this strange,
I just think some of that,
to be head of the Russian bureaucracy,
which is by definition is extremely slow and it's not on there.
But for a ministry it's also about Russian television and it's also bots secret
services to some degree.
But also we got informal actors.
We have people who officially have nothing to do with the government.
And,
uh,
at,
on the one hand,
it gives the Kremlin as what we always could deny responsibility of what we do
all the time.
But also it makes it,
these groups much more flexible and adventurous because they,
uh,
my legs,
a bureaucracy of it,
have a direct access,
does a crown done,
and they can always ask,
look,
it's a file.
Fine.
We do that on my,
the next day we can,
we can try this.
So it's actually be I on the fifth of very flexible and adventurous,
a community of people who are really committed to this fence because actually
the risks are still very slow low from him.
So I guess the answer is it's gotten harder to tell.
Yup.
Anything you would add arena.
Anything you want to add to that please?
A somewhat ironic that a,
I think today is a buttons,
the 65th birthday and as an economist published this morning,
he has no intention of,
uh,
stepping down as I think you pointed out.
Um,
and of course this article,
which is just this morning was of course talking about Nevada and yeah.
And so I guess two parts of the question from your perspective is what is his
future and why knees given how much an upper he's made,
particularly in the West,
you know,
he's on 60 minutes,
a handful of times.
So where is he going or is he not?
And then where,
because a lot of,
I think what he's done has been to catalyze somewhat of the youth and
millennials and younger people.
So what role will younger people play in the next five years?
And actually it might even be worth just giving a bit of quick context for the
group on who he is and the work he's done.
No,
I knew opposition politician who as a new way of doing policy or politics and
Russia,
uh,
him,
you know,
that are today in Russia,
uh,
opposition politicians can now access to the chosen media,
traditional mass media,
TV channels,
radio stations,
and newspapers and webs that could use website because all,
most of them aren't as a criminal's control or under the control of program and
oligarchs.
So she started,
uh,
he started,
he started to gain popularity,
are doing some songs on that.
He set up his,
uh,
he,
he set up a special channel on Youtube as,
and another channel on Youtube.
Uh,
he started it.
In fact,
he started with tweeters on Youtube Channel and,
uh,
until,
and his,
well,
his own web sites.
And He,
uh,
two years ago he got a lot of popularity that was even bigger are into Saul.
It became bigger in 2017,
four.
I don't know what reasons may be,
are maybe because of a financial crisis in Russia and a bad economic situation
may be the cause or the authoritative regime became strong.
Cousin was,
isn't it used to be,
but,
uh,
he's [inaudible] are usually,
usually regret of yours tends me,
uh,
in fact tens of millions years and tens of millions of views because a single
youtube video.
Yeah.
So that's great sale and oven oven the oven,
we'll have a as a last mass protest and Moscow,
uh,
was arrested but uh,
but uh,
any case.
So we got a is our war,
tens of thousands of people on the streets and many of them,
uh,
the students and even I am in school,
boys at school goals is that as well?
Is it as it as,
it was really unusual for Russia because previously vi we've seen only on the
people who's older than 20,
and maybe answering the question.
Um,
the interesting thing now is the bat,
uh,
previously now I only base all his activity online.
It was all this about something on line.
And right now he started building his,
um,
his network offline and it's surprisingly,
it's quiet successful.
Uh,
one regards,
the light just protest and the one to try to organize and to enlist people in
the regions.
And we got produce an 80 towns,
which is really 80,
80.
So it's really big because,
uh,
as a usual a Fiore and traditional fear about the Russian political opposition
is like,
well,
yes,
you have some,
some people voting for you in big towns,
but uh,
the rest of Russia doesn't care and that they support [inaudible] it's not the
case.
Now it's a,
it's a big new development and I think he will invest more and more resources
and more of his time and his people time into trying to build is math.
What can regions,
and it's,
as I said,
that's quite effective.
It's really interesting what might happen to him and to his ideas when he
actually started with moving is shift from on from the online,
the wall to the offline world.
Of course we have some problems,
uh,
because it's means it's a very traditional way of building a political party,
which means what you need to be ready to answer some traditional wow question is
like what you're thinking about the economic situation,
political situation on and now Crimea,
many things and he is not bad.
[inaudible] uh,
and,
but still it's a very simple
functional adds a woman.
He's in the,
and Santa was,
uh,
was the tainted I took two days ago,
four foot for 20 days.
Hmm.
Thank you.
Awesome.
In the beginning of your talk,
you mentioned that,
um,
there are very few things that could resonate with the general public when it
comes to censorship.
Um,
do you feel there is a cultural shift happening and brushed brushing society
where people's starting to respect,
uh,
freedom of speech more?
Or is it still mostly about just,
you know,
accessing to deterrence and,
and for Nagaffi this is one thing and another thing they topic of,
um,
talk to day surveillance,
censorship and beyond.
And I wanted to ask you a little bit about the beyond part.
Do you feel like part of this strategy of the government when it comes to
censorship,
censorship is to make the community complacent with it and doing it through the
idea of,
um,
censorship being necessary to,
to control,
to food,
to control the country,
to fight terrorism and to make sure we,
it was Russia grows in a stable fashion.
Well,
I would try to,
it's actually the interesting thing about,
uh,
there is a way to answer both of your question and one,
it looks like five years ago when they introduced the system,
we're trying to play some tricks like we are protecting children.
Uh,
we are doing things.
We actually,
we just doing this exactly the same thing that was first introduced by some
British.
So in a way we imitates a British approach to internet filter in and it looks
like some years ago,
actually two years ago,
they completely abandoning all pretenses.
Now it's even not about terrorist,
it's about the west.
We have the west,
they are plotting against us.
If we need to fight back,
we need to protect us.
And the,
unfortunately his visa idea is accepted by many and evens.
Um,
idea,
salt,
fog,
completer,
shuffle off.
Our infrastructure in our country is a sort of accepted by many because as the
Internet is seen as a invention as Americans,
so we need to fight back,
very installed.
For example,
that it was a crazy story just two years ago.
Uh,
how's the idea of the localization was sold to Russia?
some,
some Russian officials,
uh,
sat on from the stage of,
actually you can see in Crimea,
some of the people are playing,
uh,
Vulcraft.
They've bowel the VA,
they know they're not a capable of playing because they are couple far as
Americans.
So we need to do something about it.
And then this kind of protects,
well,
unfortunately,
are quite popular and people accepted this idea.
Second,
second class towns.
Oh,
of course.
My sense is that it's all a start to the new Samsung Samsung,
a nonpolitical like thorns websites on pornography and eh,
and Eh,
shifted very,
very soon to politics because costs,
uh,
the cause to block pop pornography websites is also politics.
It's so instruction.
Um,
thank you all again.
Thank you.